hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
for a Nibbana Belle Annabelle Annabelle
movie movie that is a spin-off and of
the conjuring that was erected by by
James Wan booth ah animal oh you tell me
what that that means it took all of it
okay
ah threw you off Brad about um the first
teaser trailer was cool I was like this
does look scary but I do want to see
more I do want to see more are you dude
are you sure well yeah we can't sleep it
I know you haven't seen any of the
trailers but the teaser for the setup of
I don't think they really even show must
be main characters yet okay so it'd be
kind of cool to see because you know
like the conjuring had a good first
trailer that [ __ ] it was just like that
scene with a bully Taylor yeah yeah well
that was yeah the first ever trailer
clip thing was just from that scene I
was like yes I don't need to see them
yeah sold me the movie like there's some
kind of family and there's the house and
some spooky shits about to go down
that's all I got and it's the seven
eight yeah then they really second
trailer which was like an actual trailer
but you like oh you get to see a lot of
names warrant oh the warrants yeah you
get to see the Warren family and you're
like it's pretty cool characters
actually okay let's watch this trip
let's do this I'm excited it's all good
I hold hands right now
you've survived you don't come out the
other side for something like this we
could please cliff to be scared this is
the last time how did I get in there
I swear it threw it out to the next day
yeah I want to buy my daughter that why
dogs gonna hate this [ __ ] Oh like pack
ah no no do not want no new selves
whoa is a cool trend it looks pretty
trippy to have a pretty good man right
anything that deals with a family with a
baby always like nah so baby so like
most haunted house movies yeah yeah now
it really does bother me I like about it
is it seems like an actual like we're
gonna haunt you and terrify you not fill
you with gore hannah movie because it's
focusing on such a small group of
characters so it's about scary the main
characters for like a good hour town
yeah like everyone that house movie I
mean yeah most times movies are just a
couple people in a place in their self
usually there's an awful lot of it well
does it seem like a haunted house movie
it sounds like it just seems like that
doll is the haunted thing well not a
haunted house movie like I'm using that
term broadly just you know like us
boo-ki things are going on and there's
either a haunted child or a haunted
house or a haunted doll or something
vaguely ghoulish and demonic is
happening to our family I mean it sounds
like the serial killer body is what
latched on to the Annabelle doll she is
here the one who stabbed the wife that
they showed blood dripping from the dead
body and then when it's animals I that
girl yeah and then looked like her one
you well yeah but is she a serial killer
I don't know what they were but I
thought it was a human for sure well
yeah there's like the spirit of that
girl is attached to Nana go yeah yeah so
we're on the same baby yeah yeah I
didn't think nothing about that said
that she was a serial killer well I
thought you were and they murdered the
neighbors today yeah that's why he went
in their room the husband he's like
you'll go get out of here oh I don't
know I mean maybe she was just like an
escaped mental this trailer should be
clearer no it shouldn't I mean it should
be clear now we're wandering now there
are there are mysteries to solve come
the day we see I like to know everything
before I watch it fall I watch every
clip every trailer and then I watch the
extra 15 minutes of
the movie has to offer me like the
amazing spider-man 2 yeah oh yeah after
new to the channel what you can do is
you can subscribe to the real rejects do
it more channel of variety and all sorts
of movie areas and sometimes we do more
than it's just not being movie related
you know we're really trying to go out
there and expand the community you know
and historical fiction mm-hmm City
Planning I got a I got a story about
slavery where all the slaves become
vampires and attack and they win the war
against humans and vampires I guess you
could have made that movie in like the
mid 70 and that was the real Civil War
okay we gotta get that get that Black
Dynamite money and go make it [ __ ]
hump they all turn into like vampires
and they [ __ ] murder a bunch of
southerners yeah make it modern David
something know where man wanted a shout
out nowhere man
something nowhere something no or men
can I please get a shout out yeah sure
you could totally have a shout out saw
something nowhere man I mean you sound
like you're confused on who you are and
where you are in life yeah I mean do you
need guidance cuz I can help you out if
it involves getting poonanny or go see
or vagina or [ __ ] I can help you out
there my man that was the most lopsided
series of synonyms yeah I kind of went
backwards on that that's not that I am
NOT a fan I can never warm up to punani
really can't do it no it just sounds
like something messy I would get it yeah
it sounds like [ __ ] maybe well I think
of poop
okay I just think of something that's
messy so I guess it's similar well when
it's [ __ ] like nice and cleansed yeah it
happens on occasion yeah you know it's
true my [ __ ] since looks pretty good
it's gonna look at it and you know don't
like this kind of humor I'm stopping all
right I literally found the line I would
really started getting like it on come
on really my stomach I was like this is
grossing me out just thinking about my
own [ __ ] right does not like Joe don't
Mike poop so something no we're men
something no we're mad jobs a shout outs
that's true that's what he does look man
if you need advice just comment and
we'll let you know something that you
need to know be like solace
dude I've given you a shout out like a
bill
times find it Mike Thompson did I miss
my shout out or was it already on a
different video I've had a couple bad
week so I need something to cheer me up
Mike Tom sanity I'm hope this shoutout
does cheer you why Thompson there's very
few good things I'm willing to do out
there in America but cheering out kids
that's one of them that's one of them
yes a noble noble cause
mmm and Cosi advice now basic rule Mike
Thompson when you're going down on a
chick the first thing I ever learn and a
lot of you guys would probably gonna all
know this one to spell the alphabet with
your tongue okay you're a kid now and
I'm sure you know your ABCs so practice
it with your tongue now and you will
satisfy a lady in the future just like
that that you really hell on that one
piece of back yeah
Adam Gonzalez what's up Ryan sounds
Hispanic actually gay pasa right I am
new to your videos and a new subscriber
and so far your bids are funny honest
and weird that's a good thing could you
give me a shout-out on your next video
yeah
Adam Gonzalez Adam Gonzalez I did an
impression of you I'm sure it was an
accurate impression of Adam Gonzales
sure he was not offended but I don't
know why would he be offended it was a
pork trail I don't much a tribute okay
to all Mexican culture oh you almost got
to the territory of like vaguely
bullshitty but I guess it's
understandable reasoning into completely
terrible reason they had him he's the
first Hispanic song gun that's cool
Oh cuz his name's Adam woman's God's are
like multiple worlds and he did like
Peter Hemans and this is whatever I
don't know what the [ __ ] they become but
they're all different beings and he's
like let's see which planets the best
and then the aliens are the ones who are
like I developed a UFO god I'm going to
hurt what can do that we can't do that
yet I mean I imagine one day we could
we've already gotten to space was people
I know that space is dangerous - space
is terrified I was just in lockdown to
go to a movie when we want to be scared
space literally yeah see it's Doty movie
all right let's go
there's no other film by computers I'm
just glad lockout as somebody's going to
yeah or something
Apollo 13 more like holo 13
has no soul level ouch gravity more like
shitty that prayer for your like review
headline yeah
shitty even gravity issues it's kind of
a stretch but you know one's a
three-syllable Ryman's - so who's up you
know yeah yeah no it's a stretch I
understand but it's there I get the
plight a gecko of the run penis genius
that's my nickname